[Música]
hola muchísimas gracias por continuar en
la pantalla de france 24 y bienvenidos a
5 minutos con hoy nos acompaña el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez médico infectólogo
de la universidad nacional de colombia
doctor pérez muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24
bueno la organización panamericana de la
salud advirtió que el kobe 19 continuará
propagándose incluso con una vacuna para
que se deben preparar entonces los
países doctor
el mensaje es que la vacuna es parte de
la solución pero el real comporta el
comportamiento humano es la completa
solución es durante la fase inmunización
es decir durante el plazo de
implementación de la vacuna no se va a
poder vacunar todo el mundo al tiempo y
en ese proceso se va a tener que
mantener la misma disciplina social
cuando se complete el proceso de
vacunación es que ya podremos hablar de
una nueva normalidad entonces el mensaje
es que no es cuando integraba con el
país sino cuando se inmunice la mayoría
de personas en el país que se acepta una
nueva normalidad significaría esto que
las esperanzas no deben digamos estar
únicamente direccionadas en una vacuna
que decirle a la gente a la población a
lo largo de todo el mundo
la solución va a llegar la solución muy
probablemente es una vacuna y hay otras
alternativas terapéuticas pero lo que
tenemos que hacer en este mundo en este
momento es que no nos de coronavirus que
disminuyamos la posibilidad de que nos
dé una enfermedad sintomática y por eso
el distanciamiento físico el uso de
cubrebocas estar en espacios bien
ventilados no lo va a asegurar ese
comportamiento es lo que va a
permitirnos llegar en el mejor escenario
para que cuando una vacuna elimine el
problema de luke colon aviv ahora la
apuesta no por el mecanismo conocido
como kóvacs al que se han unido 156
países sin estados unidos ni china
tendría dosis para finales del año 2021
en la pregunta que surge es mientras
tanto que dr
si estos son mecanismos que hacen los
países para poder acceder con la
recuerden que son 7.500 millones de
humanos y las vacunas por más capacidad
que haya pueden ser dos mil tres mil
millones de vacunas que se fabrican en
año como se priorizan las vacunas esas
estrategias que hacen los países para
tener la igualdad en la cobertura
vacunal y que se prioricen las
poblaciones de alto riesgo para ser
susceptibles a vacunación mientras se
llega a una vacuna universal esta es una
estrategia de las otras que hay para
poder tener la vacuna en forma universal
pero no vamos a tener vacuna
inmediatamente para todo el mundo no
esto es un proceso que se mueran unos
años habla usted doctor de poblaciones
de alto riesgo aunque le puede esperar
entonces a los países del continente
americano que tienen a seis países entre
los diez con el mayor número de
contagios de todo el mundo
eso ha dado un gran problema que tenemos
en américa latina que es la pobreza en
nuestros sistemas de salud somos muy
reactivos no preventivos y el
comportamiento y la disciplina física y
social y además de eso de la mesta de la
política con la ciencia yo creo que la
vacuna va a llegar va a ser la solución
no tenemos que perder ese optimismo pero
mientras tanto tenemos que mantenernos
en distanciamiento del alejamiento
procurar que no nos dé la enfermedad
para llegar en las mejores condiciones a
américa latina es la región del mundo
más golpeada pero que también tiene la
mejor oportunidad para llevar a todos
los habitantes a las mejores condiciones
para inmunización doctor sé que ese que
quizás difícil de responder la siguiente
pregunta no pero está en la mente de
todas las personas a lo largo de todo el
mundo es posible prever algún escenario
de cuando todo volverá a la normalidad
y la pregunta que todos nos hacemos la
expectativa es que en el 2022 asumamos
una normalidad en el último semestre
2022 en el año 2021 hacer el plan de la
implementación y de inmunización pero al
menos las vacunas tienen a diferencia de
12 meses entre dosis es decir que uno no
es que se vacuna el otro día no le de
coronavirus se muere tiempo dos o tres
meses la implementación gradual en los
países y todo el 2021 y al menos el
primer semestre del 2022 va a estar en
esa dinámica y vamos a volver a la
normalidad el problema es que ninguna
pandemia ha demorado menos de 18 meses
nosotros por mayor tecnología hemos
aprendido que tenemos que tener la
paciencia necesaria para poder superar
esta crisis doctor carlos eduardo pérez
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24 a nuestra audiencia le decimos
como siempre que continúen cuidándose en
la medida de lo posible y sigan
informando se en france 24 y en france
24 punto com
[Música]